[Music]
hannah
is with us in myrtle beach hi hannah
welcome to the ramsay show
hello dave and christy i'm excited and
terrified to talk to y'all
oh don't be terrified how can we help
what's going on right now
um i'm looking for a little bit of
advice my husband and i
are getting out of debt for our third
time
in our marriage and i can never seem to
get past
baby step three i could never seem to
save the emergency fund
my husband is a full-time pastor a
full-time roofer
and so he works all the time so i take
care of the finances i take care of the
budget
everything my question is um
how can i have him help me when it comes
to the budget and the finances and
everything
he's willing to help but he doesn't know
how to help
um he also does not spend any money
whatsoever so he's an extreme
favor i'm the spender so i'm just
looking for a little bit of advice to
get us
onto baby step 3 and past baby step 3.
i'm so tired of
feeling like i'm doing it by myself
hmm i know this is not what you're
asking hannah but i want to go back to
why you
get yourself back into debt three
different times what's going on
why do you keep going back into this
thing it is
it is me just losing all
power and will to not get back into that
um i get i get past baby step two
and it's not huge that like i'm not i'm
not in big debt right now but
it's sorry i'm very nervous that's okay
your your your husband's dad was a
roofer
no no uh my husband is a roofer what was
your husband's dad do
um he right now he
he's working at a plant what did he do
when your husband was growing up
um he worked in a chemical plant okay in
a factory
okay all right um
your husband is a good man he loves god
he works and he works hard he however
is not functioning like your husband is
functioning like your son
right you're the mommy and you make all
the adult decisions and carry all the
adult
responsibilities he just goes to work
and if you actually gently
call him out on that um he will respond
because he loves his wife
and that would sound like this honey i
need your help
i can't carry the weight of all of this
by myself anymore
number one i can't handle the stress
number two when i do it by myself we go
back into that
and you work so hard you're such a good
man
but i've got to have you emotionally
carry
your half of the finances of this
household
and here's one thing i would add way of
saying man up
here's one thing i would add when you
have this conversation
when you have this conversation which is
is going to be so important
i want you to be extremely specific
with what help looks like to you yes
because if you say help me and he says
okay i'll help you and then
six months goes by in your mind help is
more overtime
yeah you need to be very like even when
you say i need help i don't even know
that you know this will be good for you
to think about okay here's what this
would look like does it look like paying
bills does it look like showing up for
the budget meeting
what does it look like specifically
tactically
visually and then connect there and
allow him to speak into it obviously
but expectations have got to be crystal
clear i'm not
making any more financial decisions by
myself
there's a there's a great one you have
to help me make the financial decisions
we're going to look at the budget
together and you're going to feel the
strain of the bill paying with me
yeah yeah because you feel the weight
when the stuff is when it gets tight you
get the you get the sweat in the palm of
your hands and across the top of your
eyebrow
you get that feeling that tightness in
your throat he doesn't have that feeling
at all
he needs that feeling it will change and
it will help you
because the good news is he's a saver
and so he's going to hold you
accountable now the bad news is
he's going to hold you accountable so
your your days of being in control by
yourself are about done
yeah yeah you're going to be careful
with what you wished for because you're
going to
have somebody report to with all this
spending and going back into debt but
it's going to be a great thing it's
going to be such a healthy
conversation where you're on the same
page let's do it he's meeting you there
let's do it this way i'm going to put
you in
mz plus for a year free as my gift
and and the way you can phrase the
conversation then is honey
i need your help i can't do this by
myself anymore it's wearing me out i
need you to help me carry the weight
of the adult decision-making of the
money i've been doing it by myself and i
just can't do it anymore
i've got to have you help me do that and
the way we're going to start that is
we're going to go through this class
together
right here online we'll sit on the couch
and do it after the kids go to bed
and i know you're tired so am i i'm sick
and tired though and so you've got to
help me with this
and just like if you came to him and
said honey i'm sick i need you to put
the kids to bed
he would do that he would do that
he would carry his share of the weight
he would do chores that he normally
doesn't
do if you asked him for help because he
loves you
but you need to be very specific because
guys we don't do subtlety
you have to tell us what it is and then
say it again a couple more hundred times
if you get him in this class together
and you guys are making the budget
together on every dollar and you're
making your decisions together
it's going to give you what you want and
some things you didn't even want that
are coming your way
but you're going to it's going to change
the whole thing so that'll be a way you
can do it so you hold on and i'll
pick up uh i'll have i'll pick up i'll
have kelly pick up
and get you signed up for ramsey plus
and you can you can do the stuff you're
supposed to do then and you guys get in
there and
get into financial peace university get
the every dollar budget going together
because this is what's going on so
christy there's a thing
and you guys out there listening i'm
gonna piss some of you off but just get
ready i'm not it's not it doesn't come
from a mean place
it's observation and it's not always
true but in a lot
of blue-collar families
mama takes care of the money and daddy
does the work
and that's a modeling thing of what it
means to be a husband
that he got from his dad and so he moved
in
and now mama's taking care of the money
and but there's a
um in in oftentimes
in white collar families it can be the
same way if you grew up
in a blue collar family because the
generational what's taught exactly what
how it's taught to you who is this what
you do now you know in
your case you grew up a single mom's
household where
she's making all the decisions and so
you would never even think of
not being involved in the decisions in
your household right it wouldn't occur
to you
because of your upbringing it's
interesting though because matt and i
have had such interesting discussions
as newlyweds and still present day of
how we as a generation but also
as a couple do things different than our
parents did not only because of how they
worked
but even just uh raising kids and
expectations it it all is different we
have to define it for ourselves what
that's going to look like
and but and you do you do have to
clarify these where these roles came
from
rachel does a good job with that in the
know yourself know your money book and
the know yourself
money assessment for couples that's
another thing you can do is jump into
that because that gets into the
family of origin what how family how
money was handled in the household you
grew up in because that affects then how
you're communicating with your spouse
about it yeah
so you could take that know yourself
money assessment for couples you ought
to you guys
a bunch of you ought to take it uh you
can get it at ramsey solutions in the
store it's
inexpensive and it's really really a
powerful assessment
it'll open up things for you like
cray-cray man it's nuts it's it'll blow
your mind
this is the ramsay show